[Music]
alright man so why don't we just start
with what's going on like give me your
take on where we're at right now I
really want to hear like your
perspective on what you think is going
on I mean right now it just feels like
it feels like we're at a spot where
people realize that they have to use
your voice now and and I mean everybody
like we're starting to see like a team
effort to battle racism like we realize
black people can't do it alone and white
people have to speak up and I'm starting
to see that that's actually what's
happening and but I won't about every
white person out there that's helping or
that's thinking about helping I want
y'all to understand that there's
probably not gonna be any awards there's
not gonna be any pat on the back there's
not gonna be a high-five like you're
doing it just because you know it's
right and I think as long as they
understand that you know cuz I see you
like well I I went to this March it's
like yeah that's great but there's a lot
more going on as far as everything
that's going on I think it's been going
on is just getting revealed yeah this is
not anything new I mean not to call them
out but John's older than me so I'm sure
he's seen more than me and just from
like I grew up in Ferguson that we
talked about before yeah I've seen worse
almost you know so it's just like it's
time to end it and the only way to end
it is together yeah yeah I mean I think
they're there look those changes at the
highest level politically require a
certain level of will right and that
will is a reflection of popular support
and I've never seen this level of
popular support so it's about figuring
out how to harness that and channel it
in the right direction so that it
doesn't just dissipate and then we're
back to some version of normal because
and I think like what we don't want to
do is make the mistake
of what happened with Ferguson like we
talked about Ferguson last time you
growing up there and everything that
happened there in 2014 and I think there
was a sense that after that there were
gonna be some changes and we didn't
really see that right this does feel
different to me I don't know if it does
to you no good I think there's an
opportunity here I know I'm sitting I
talked I told John before be quiet most
of the time no I don't want you to be
quiet
my patience is up I'm 56 years old so in
1964 the Civil Rights Act was passed so
if you were born before 1964 black folks
had no civil rights and we still had to
fight to the point where Martin Luther
King got killed four years later and
then the riots then forty-seven days
after the riot the civil riot was
enacted mm-hmm that's what it took
effect it got to go literally the only
way this country or most people have
ever ever ever dealt with things is when
it hurt them in a pocket though I think
it's the right thing to do no I don't
think anybody's stuff should be burned I
don't think anybody should be in this
situation but you know what it's from
what it seems like it seems like it's a
lot of talk and it does not feel real so
the change doesn't have to come like
John said from both sides the change the
reason what he means by the change you
got to come from both sides is black
folks need to say enough is enough and
white folks need to say what do you need
mm-hmm that's change they can't help us
white folks can't help us we got help
ourselves and we got to do it this way
period like you know sometimes it we
know money we do we got a we got a now
crowd fun and sauce to ourselves we now
have to build things that help us as a
community we now have to separate like
we we got to take a second we got
step away mm-hmm integration was at this
point we love the allies but we as black
folk will gust up away that step away
and figure out which one of us are like
Candace Owens and which one of us I like
kill a Mike yeah this is difference and
this is the problem when you separate
everybody stays sip but we have to pick
a side we have to either say we're gonna
go this way or we're gonna go that way
and we have to make a decision that
those on this side raise their ways and
those on this side raise theirs before
we try to mirror we try to put it
together
and what we got was a Vietnam War and
drugs in our community I was ten so we
got to change that look if you I think
we got to be we got to act like
Americans when we didn't when they no
longer wanted to be subjects of Great
Britain hmm and Malcolm X said you know
if you talk about a revolution there's
nothing nice about it it's nothing cute
about it
and if it doesn't if it doesn't we're
gonna go back to the Norma see an
enormous II was wrong hmm and that's why
when you hear you know make America
great again we're like when the [ __ ] was
it great for us like you know like we
had some moments you know like put it
this way for people out there that
listen when they when you when your
rebuttal is time people had a grant it
had a good they had Michael Jordan or
they had Barack Obama if you could only
think of five people as the barometer of
we had a good that's not good
like you don't say like if people died
no we everyone knows it wasn't good the
deal is what we're gonna do like do we
send money to the NCAA NCAA same right
I'm sorry
n double acp do we send the money to
black lives matter
what happens when you send the money
there when they put this in we're gonna
hit corruption and this got bought
Bentley and three houses mm like what do
what what are we gonna hear what is
gonna be the move do we send it to
Minister Farrakhan do we send it to our
shopton do we sent it to dr. Umar
Johnson like we literally need
leadership one one thought process I
would say and I don't know if it needs
to be led by a religious fraction or not
I was gonna post something the other day
and rich this is the deal I'm on this
show
cuz John asked me to be on uh-huh and I
said I'm here reluctantly no of course
I'm angry I am because I'm enraged but
you know me being a Buddhist you don't
ever react in anger but like I got 17
year old daughter and 23 year old
daughter who say to me how'd you let it
get this far
mm like I was in charge right but then
I'm like yeah how did I why did I I post
it on my post it said know your position
make your choice now and I was literally
to as many black folks that because they
knew what it was like you gonna play the
back huh
you gonna play the front and you're
gonna sit in the house you're gonna be
in the field all those different words
came about and I was like we have to
literally unlearn everything
if we don't unlearn it we're gonna start
acting like my boy Simon I'd say Solomon
said he had a book called black
privilege and people said what are you
talking about he was like you gotta
think about it he was like sometimes we
act in a certain way as if we're on this
side looking at black people like what
the hell yeah when we supposed to be
looking at ourselves like what the hell
mm-hmm
so I just said pickiest pick pick
exactly what position you want to be in
history
you you know you want to Spock it that's
why I decided to open up my own stuff
we're going to things and I'm making
everybody else money posting their stuff
when I was like I don't if I don't show
these cats especially nowadays financial
freedom and literacy and growth and
invested into my own thoughts and this
is why no one else is gonna do yeah well
you're I mean both you guys are black
business owners I mean you got a million
businesses yeah right I mean I can't
keep track seem to change a lot the
College on up sometimes like a man is
really you okay do you know it's called
a seventy seventy two means of diversify
yeah well you got if like literally the
72 names of God in Hebrew so liddy if
you can have 72 streams of income as we
not only help yourself you're helping
everyone really associated so I have I
have seven right now and you got you a
vegan smart right here vegan smart
badass vegan as a as a corporation to
and in the production company hungry for
justice and that's something we you know
I people don't realize like the black
dollar black consumers spend 1.2
trillion dollars a year
how many black businesses are put up
front to make that money it's like
you're spinning in is going all the way
from your community or your people now
it's like oh well what if you invested
that back into the community back into
black corporations and then other black
corporations come about and it just it's
a trickle of fader you know that 1.2
tree there's a lot of money there's a
lot of baby shoes you know it's not is
not going back to the black community
though mm-hmm so this spin is all going
out it's not coming back in so how do
you catalyze entrepreneurship in your
community mmm why we open up planet
health in Compton five four six West
Compton is that your your restaurant
yeah so this is a trip because it's a
small restaurant
but it was like a strip mall and then it
had like empty lot next to it so I got
in touch with a guy Moses who was making
the generators to make air make water
out of the atmosphere and I hopefully
gonna talk to Ron Finley again about
putting a farmers market there and then
if we sell here
aha coffee there's a stage for people to
talk and get the words out learned
things that's called small cafe and then
it's a clothing store but what all stuff
made in LA so literally we did that
across the street from new body got to
say that new era because we wanted just
to take over Compton Avenue I just had
that mentality and then I opened up
plant organics cafe Oh in San Bernardino
and a brown neighborhood so I put one in
a black neighborhood and wanted a brown
neighborhood and health and wellness so
it still fits with what we do yeah but
it's I wanted to get rid of the I wanted
to make an oasis I got I wanted to get
rid of the lack of food and lack of
knowledge and health in the black
community right I want to get back to
one thing you said earlier about about
leadership right now you know what is
different about this moment versus 60
for MLK you know Malcolm X is that there
is no iconic leader at the moment for
this that leadership is distributed and
you know how does that impact this
movement like both of you guys are are
amongst those leaders you both have huge
profiles you have people who really care
what you think and I'm sure you take
that responsibility seriously and you
know think long and hard about how you
message to your respective communities
but you know what does leadership mean
in this moment in black lives matter
it means everything I tell you because a
way everybody is getting the information
is literally the same way it's it's it's
not diverse so all the information comes
from television and Instagram so you're
not you don't have a paper that had been
or you have a couple of papers but none
that we don't go and pick up the paper
now and read it the same way things can
be blocked and on on on Facebook and on
Instagram and and YouTube and those are
the sources we get our information from
it just know we have to we have the
paper and you know in Inglewood but you
know it's not that everybody is running
out to see what the news is where you
used to turn it on CNN and believe in
that used to turn it on Fox and believe
in that so the problem with the
leadership is who do we trust to be 100
percent on this side and never gonna
waver and the only person that was like
that was Colin Kaepernick Colin
Kaepernick put his neck on the shoulder
like Muhammad Ali did and but he's not
saying hey I want to be the leader of
this movement right so that the problem
is we just have to find out where those
you know do you go after a celebrity do
you listen to Dave Chappelle or do you
check like we don't know that Dick
Gregory quit being a comedian to be
activists yeah so it's just but he's
passed so it's like trying to figure out
who and what side to move on because we
have been rich footlight for a better
word we have been literally massaged
into believing it's gonna be okay mm-hmm
we've got a high it's gonna be okay we
got a literally not feeling we got in
and who I don't know who we we listen to
it's a big trust factor with it yeah
it's a big trust because this time we
want to move away from we want to get
out of it you know I know I do is it
because you gotta think about like there
are so many people with ulterior motives
it's like so yeah maybe they might come
in they might want to help em I wanna do
something it's like but what's ulterior
motive and track records have shown like
it's not a big track right now you don't
say it on both sides so it's like who do
we want to trust and who wants to take
that cuz like maybe three four years ago
Kaepernick had that energy he wanted to
do that now he's like [ __ ] yeah listen
to me you know this is I mean like you
know I I moved on cuz ya'll don't wanna
listen to me yeah so it's kind of like
that like and then who wants to be torn
down by the other side - right because
whoever is gonna be that leader they're
gonna is gonna be a mission for other
people to go after them mm-hmm you know
like the premise of black lives matter
there's another corrupt about there's
none but there have been people out from
day one the money's going here the
leadership is dead you know like right
the core of it is good of course you're
gonna get people that trickle in that
aren't like a hundred percent at the at
the protest they turn into looters and
they do riots it's like okay do you
really think that the people of black
lives matter is out there the ones that
are literally starting the fires are
doing this and that like well and I'm
sure you get on top people that with
black lives matter so much why do black
people kill each other like do you think
the people in black lives matter are the
ones that's killing other black people
like do you think like I got the answer
for that too and I have to tell people
because I know I sounded very strong
when I first came on but being pro black
is not anti way no I you know well
there's a lot of moral confusion out
there right now I don't have that like
literally I'm about to sound like a
white guy no my wife is my wife is is is
half Caucasian and
some of my best friends are white no
doesn't sound crazy the other way right
but but I know but I just want people to
understand that it's like it's not the
OJ trial this is not the Rodney King
like but the fact that we could even go
back to that on how people were so
separate how separate the country was
and how like black people that didn't
even know who OJ was was on his like
that kind of stuff we got to get away
from you know so and I'm glad that my
daughter's age
different than ours are is they kind of
see no color mmm that's how are they
doing with all this they're angry my
daughter
Giovanna is 32 she's she's losing it and
I had to tell her yo chill I had to say
chill I was like cuz you're transferring
something else into this like don't
transfer you've got to be smart about
how this gets done but the the the one
thing that I was saying that I love the
allies that are on our side but but we
just want police brutality fixed all the
rest of that [ __ ] we don't want to look
we just want cops to stop killing us I
want I literally Drive the whitest of
white cars in the world I Drive a Prius
I did that thing I drove a Prius and I
still got pulled over gotcha
no I Drive a Tesla and and I'm driving
and it's even white it is why would I
drive this car and if I see a police
officer I still second look and I was
like what the hell of 56 I'm still doing
that and you do I said till second look
and I just want that part to stop have
you had gnarly encounters yeah when I
was playing for the Miami Heat
nine
tips 2,000 1994-95 so I'm hanging out my
brother Michael and I'm working for
Toyota so I get a Land Cruiser every
4000 huh but it's like big participant
Toyota was throwing it out so I had this
big beautiful white one and I'm getting
on the causeway we're leaving the club I
don't drink or smoke so and we're
driving and the cops pull us over on the
causeway and tell me to cut the car off
turn the kid drop the keys out of doors
: open the door with my right hand get
out and walk backwards mmm why their
guns was drawn then they got me Turner I
put my face down but the license John
Salley
yo sorry dude we had we heard somebody
you know I stole a white truck like this
on the beach and said my brother was
like taking the [ __ ] he was like come on
we're cool right yo man nobody and my
brother was like if I were to trip you
would've shot me if I was stumble going
backwards you would you would have shot
me and it never clicked until my brother
told me that mm-hmm he was like Sally
real cool right
thinking got in the car we get 20
minutes from my house he say [ __ ] I
still couldn't say anything I was like
yeah but I got about six of them but
they become so I become so numb to it
until I saw George floor it was amazing
it was like like those girls calling in
a Harvey Weinstein and Bill Cosby like
oh hi yeah sighing I before something
clicked and I was like and I could have
been I could have been me and the trip
is I posted today a white dude going
through the same thing so it wasn't just
black it was police brutality then
that's what I keep saying to people they
keep thinking I'm making it black no I'm
making it police brutality and my
cousin's like a chief was a top captain
my other cousins are chief and the
police the fire department my brothers
correction officer
get it but they still overstep they bow
so when you hear defund the police no no
I said fund the police so now we could
know what they need to do is if we got
snitches in jail
we need snitches in the police
department find out which ones on the
air believe that the Aryan race is
strong to find them tag them get them
out what they gonna do is start their
own police force so now you gotta
watched it so we watched black Klansmen
we watched Mississippi Burning we saw
all these all these things are imitating
life we watched it knowing what it was
about
police brutality now we need to stop it
mm-hmm yeah I think it's obvious that
that we need a healthy police force you
know I don't know why anyone would be
calling for the abolition of the police
I'm certainly not anti cop but but I
think we need to figure out how to
allocate those funds appropriately so
they're going in the river buddy we got
to train these people better they need
to be able to manage their emotions
under pressure they need to be
adequately trained with firearms they
need to know how to handle high conflict
situations like it just if there's
anything that comes out of all of these
videos it's that these people are ill
equipped for high-stress situations they
should stand now they're not racist
right but even even even one a lot of
them need to know the law we need to
retrain police officers to know the law
and know the right that's the deal they
don't know the rights they believe
they're above the law exactly so when
you don't know the rights at a citizen
you will violate them right power is
corrupting absolute power is absolutely
corrupting so if you think I got the gun
in the badge and you know you're gonna
[ __ ] yeah who you I'm [ __ ] with a
badge right that means I get the right
to kick your ass whenever I feel like it
well that is a mentality it wasn't just
Eddie doing it in the movie that's a
mentality when I said when we know that
the
that everybody is writing and protesting
it's not I'm black you're white right it
sounds like it but what we're protesting
is police brutality mm-hmm period and
then they need to know that is its
consequences to their actions right now
like you said with them thinking they're
above the law
just like yeah I can whip your ass
there's nothing wrong with it
you know saying like that's the
mentality right now is like if I anybody
if they find out they can do something
and then later on they realize oh
nothing's gonna happen to me their
morality you that their paradigm shifts
for them like well I've noticed it's
wrong but I get away with it every day
and layer on top of that the fact that
that opportunity is attractive for a
certain person who gets into that field
won't work because of whatever trauma or
abuse that person suffered in their life
that that makes that java sound
appealing they're gonna do Robocop
was it Robocop it was Robocop yeah
Robocop's about to come and then
everybody is up shits Creek I'm sure
you've had run-ins with the police -
right yeah one case that always sticks
out to me is that I was I was in college
to play college ball I was going to a
classmate's house to meet up with her
and they lived in a better neighborhood
you know this is I lived in Ferguson
they live in a better neighborhood I'm
riding over I got this on I nato's
mobile if anybody ever is beat up
it's a hoopty whatever I'm driving it
and I noticed the cop get behind me and
mind you I'm still looking for her house
cuz I don't really so I am driving a
little slow and then he puts the lights
on I'm like and automatically like you
say like fear like I remember just a
segue I remember I put out a post about
three or four years ago and I was like
for everybody out here I want you to
answer if you get pulled over what's the
first job that goes your mind most white
people were like oh you know maybe a
ticket this and that most black people
like I might [ __ ] die so that's a big
shift for people to understand like yeah
we might even if I don't die
with some kind of injury like that's for
a ticket whatever so he's pulling me
over but I waited til I got like more in
front of her house cuz I always gonna
run the King I'm like I want witnesses
like what everybody happened to me this
before cellphones that cameras uh-huh it
was like 90 97 something like that so
I'm like all right so I get there but I
called her I'm like hey I'm outside the
cops just pulled me over I'm just
letting you know in case something
happens so he comes up he's got a
unflappable
and he's like what are you doing here
that's that's the first question like
I'm not allowed to be okay oh well I
mean that with a classmate we're uh
we're about to do our paper together my
bookbag is right here a don't move your
arms my bad I'm just showing you my boot
baggage right here so now for the cops
have showed up at by the time we keep
getting our conversation going he said
why don't you stop when I first turned a
light on I was like well I was nervous
I just want make sure those witnesses
didn't say no you stop when you when the
lights come on I'm like well I was in
the middle of the street - so pull over
and he gets my license registration goes
back to the car I'm telling him like I'm
still a Silas here come outside on a
porch
her father was like a state official
some kind so he comes out he said hey
what's going on they're like oh this guy
he meets the description of the guy him
and the car meet the description of the
guy that just robbed a grocery store hmm
around the corner I don't like what damn
like was he in a cut-off t-shirt like I
just can't play ball you know like who
robs a store that's like so many stories
though it's okay he's terribly and no
mind you um I I am I'm a 20 year old guy
you know I'm not even I'm nervous as
hell
you know like everybody's like oh if you
just comply I'm like man when the fear
kicks in you like dude I might die right
now like you don't know what you're
gonna do so I'm sitting there waiting on
everything to go through finally they
come back luckily they stayed on the
porch and waited and I think that that
literally made this whole story change
so finally they gave
papers back no he's not the guy when
they go come back to my classmates
father he calls into the office or
whatever cuz they just want to check
like was there a robbery they're like no
there hasn't been a robbery at any
grocery store in that area in the last
like five years just made it out so he
just made the [ __ ] up but I just didn't
fit like I should have been in any way
right now mind you the classmate was
black too but she has like Alexis and
I'm riding riding tonight even like it
was just so I don't tell you like I was
nervous like the whole time like the
whole time but it was wearing a cut-off
t-shirt like well you ran a crop top
yeah maybe you got pulled over for the
Kratt type lime-green it was like a
basketball shirt so you know but it like
but it pisses you off afterwards like
say why would you even [ __ ] with
somebody like that for no reason no I'm
not saying there's not bad people out
there so the guy just he saw the car
he's like this is a this is a tweaked
ride this guy's got like he looks like
he's black like lights up yeah
yeah he shouldn't be in his neighborhood
it's a beat-up car like the cars beat
the [ __ ] up so he's like nah this car
should be in this area what's going on
I'm like but if I'm so it was but it's
so many stories like that I mean I've
had I've had more onions myself but it's
like and that's the messed up part cuz
you you you're kind of powerless because
they have supposedly absolute power and
absolute power corrupts you it makes you
believe that anything other than you is
lesser mm-hmm white black purple if if
we don't change the way that thought
process is like the other day excuse me
I forgot his name but the brother got
killed in a windes parking lot in
Atlanta right okay
he's standing up hash our conversation
art Brooks yeah he's having a
conversation
yeah he's tipsy he doesn't know his
right he doesn't have to take the
breathalyzer test next you know he's
wrestling and then as I'm watching it
they go we'll look this is when he
turned around and points the stun gun
well he pointed a stun gun and then the
cop shot him with a real good right so
why if he felt threatened in the back
did he feel threatened by a stun gun
then he should well he stole my son gun
so the only other gun I had to shoot him
with was that so it it's it gets to a
point where you got to stop giving
excuses it cannot we cannot have any
more excuses
we can't have George Floyd that sense
George Floyd seven other people get
murdered yeah we murdered a murdered the
kid in Palmdale who they found hung
suicide yeah well we have to it's crazy
that's the problem with the world you
know paying attention to this so closely
in a spotlight on police behavior that
these kinds of things would happen
you got protests for police brutality
where police are being brutal against
the people that are protest there's like
nobody sees this [ __ ] hmm like they were
out there it gets confused because you
have looting and like people like it has
nothing but the forty attention gets
dispersed yeah but they're doing it to
people that aren't looting is like are
you we all have the right to peacefully
protest whether it's Annie in a football
game whether it's out on the street
whatever it is we all have that right
eluding in every single riot
there's looting right every that's why
it has a name yeah and half the people
that are looting have [ __ ] to do with
the actual calls loot there's a
difference between looting and rioting
rioting is breaking some [ __ ] and
tearing some [ __ ] up looting is walking
out with Louis Vuitton it has nothing to
do with you and fluid like you got
people walking out with eight Nike boxes
David throwbacks though Nordstrom at the
Grove and that's where I gotta say the
white chick but I had did you see the
one when the when the newscaster is say
yes what maybe she biggest thing about
the white chick she was walking slow you
always see everybody else when I'm
trying not to get caught she was like
this [ __ ] fit I love that kind of I
didn't see video of people walking down
the street with bags and then lines of
cops across the street doing nothing
because they were focused on you know
whatever else and just letting that go
they can't do anything about it in sure
there's another video where it's like
three cops talking to a white lady while
she's spray-painting the building and it
oh you literally hear to say oh you
should put George for his name up there
like the cop tells it like did I doing
that it's a white lady they're not doing
nothing to her like they don't say
anything wrong like it's don't allies
those police officer yeah those allies
we need them like people are
opportunists there's another video of a
lady like literally walking up this
guy's like trying to board up his store
and he's got the drill and somebody
caught the lady doing it she runs up to
the guy to ask if she take a picture
with him he hands her the drill she's
got the drill her husband takes a
picture over they get back in the car I
leave yeah it was a ban steroids yeah
wait that was the most egregious one
because it was so blatant like she
literally gets out of the Benz walks up
that's the borrow the guys do poses with
it like she's helping yeah it's the
picture touch what I mean we try we try
like who do we trust like what's what's
a direct what is real yes really I don't
know we have these incredibly powerful
images and videos that are going viral
we're all consuming them we're trying to
make sense of what's happening and that
kind of butts up against this insane new
cycle where we're not sure what's
real and what isn't it's all very
disorienting just to find solid ground
like where are we standing and and you
know to talk to you know continue on
that idea of act of being an ally ally
ship like how can like someone like
myself be an effective ally first thing
I would ask you riches to check yourself
you have to check you have to check for
your own because we all have prejudices
right because we're American we watch
Archie Bunker we watched Jeffersons we
watch good times we watch Sanford and
Son we watch friends that had no black
people into the second-to-last season we
watched like we watched these shows that
kind of structure our pop culture so the
first thing you got to check yourself
for your own your own inefficiencies or
your own like check who you are and once
you check who you are and you check and
you check your ego and you check where
you believe you are that's up that's it
we watch each person to be as strong as
that person could possibly be and if
that person really wants to be a lie
they got to make sure that they are okay
with what they see to give example I had
a friend in Miami and he was cool he was
always with us and then this girl he
liked started dating my brother and he
said she's ruined I go what do you mean
like he doesn't have a big penis that I
don't don't believe hi she was like
enough you know I was like he's like no
she's ruined like no other like cool
like no other white guys gonna want her
after this and I'm like whoa so I had to
check him I said what do you mean by
that he didn't get it he still to this
day probably doesn't well maybe now he
does but he didn't understand what he
meant or what he was feeling so that's
why I say check yourself
I checked myself a thousand times before
getting here on what not to say what to
say and how to be as direct without
anger and with a thought as possible
mm-hmm because I do have I grew up in an
Italian Jewish neighborhood my first
friends were probably white and black
besides my brothers and Ronnie Rosen
bound is still my one of my best friends
and we check each other constantly
constantly and you know we won't even
make we're back in the day we would make
jokes you know because it means but now
we figure out maybe those jokes that we
make aren't so good for the psyche
either so I constantly check myself
that's the first thing I think yeah and
I think it also has to be a point where
as far as holding yourself accountable
that's huge and you have to look back
and say damn I was a part of that too
like and being okay with that not
beating yourself up as an ally you have
to understand like Oh dad when they did
crack their joke and every every white
person I know I don't care how much they
tried to dye it has heard a family
member a co-worker a friend whatever it
is when they wouldn't know anything
anybody else was looking they slipped in
inward and some joke or or they would be
in dead serious
telling a parent like I posted a couple
weeks ago about this white girl I was
talking to her parents and the parents
were like we're not black people want to
be in the ghetto they don't want to
succeed you know that's that's that's
their problem and the white girls like
no that's not the problem say yeah but
they're like animals and this and that
like this like this is still going on
today well you see it I'm saying so for
people to see that you have to
understand that everybody has to speak
up this little seven I think you're 17
or something like that
if this 17 year old girl can speak up
everybody has to speak up and you have
to nip it in the bud you literally have
to when you hear something racist you
see something racist
speak up about it I think people are we
talked about it earlier are too
uncomfortable always hoggin gray
yeah they're too uncomfortable with
being shunned like no you're not gonna
be liked by everybody but at least be if
somebody don't hate you let them hate
you for doing the right thing you know
there's a lot of people like I know
that's wrong over there but I'm not
gonna say anything because my family and
friends might not talk to me alright if
those people don't want to talk to you
for doing the right thing [ __ ] them like
literally like that that's showing you
their character yes I think yeah I get
that I mean I think that's an example of
egregious overt racism mm-hmm I think
the real the harder hill to climb and
the more pernicious problem it's kind of
what you were speaking to just like the
idea that that uh that there are a lot
of people most people who who will tell
you I'm not racist you know and I don't
have a racist bone in my body and I
don't see color and the blind spot for
them and for myself is is that is the
systemic aspect of all of this like when
you have watched all those television
programs growing up like I grew up in a
white neighborhood I mean there there's
you know I went to school some with some
black people but it's like I'm I'm not I
didn't I wasn't reared in black culture
right and and so you were well I was
culture pop culture yeah sure in sports
and all of that but this has brought up
for me the work that I need to do to
like unravel that knot and and to kind
of identify those those blind spots that
I have within myself because you know I
I would I would look you straight in the
eye and say I've never done anything
racist I don't harbor racist thoughts
and all of that but because of the way I
was raised and the people I've
surrounded myself my whole life it's
impossible that there isn't some kind
deeply embedded imprint that I need to
like look at and unravel you said you
said I said just before a guy said I
don't have a racist bone in my body I
said no but you gotta race his heart not
you that's yeah
what I mean to give you an example I
grew up in a white neighborhood you said
that hmm
so you knew mm-hmm right you knew yeah
well that's what I mean you grew in a
neighborhood that was white right that
means you grew up in a neighborhood that
separated you from black people right
that's racist so from the beginning of
your being
they separated you from us because of
their thought and fear of us so when you
only know this when you see this you're
only when you see it you go mommy what's
that they give you the cliff note
oh that's them over there right so that
starts it that starch racism when they
separated you and when they didn't
include in the beginning so that's where
it starts the other part is
visualization as a young young we I said
this I said what needs to be done nobody
wants to do right everybody wants to be
a martyr but they forget you got to die
yeah definitely
so no one wants to do what needs to be
done and when I say it I lose so-called
followers I put myself in a position but
this is it I'm gonna say it on your show
because I love you the only way to erase
racism is to take the picture of white
Jesus out of every Church in the world
mm-hmm
if you don't erase the thought of God
being white it's going to constantly
stay this way every I was going to post
every statue they're taken down with
Confederate they need to go on a black
church and take the white Jesus off the
wall and they won't do it
mm-hmm because the white Jesus was
established a cross to do exactly what
it's doing but this is what got us to
this point in Brazil I was in Bahia
Brazil there's 365 churches in the city
about you this is the first place that
they the first place they did slaves
they bring slaves in to Baia they they
still they will show you the
dances the kappa waaat oh they will show
you the the the cells where they bring
you up from it's it's a whole tour 365
churches so every day you can go to a
different church and worship jesus
christ and every picture in there is
what mmm
there's gold flaking on the wall people
living in the streets there's it's
always been this way
so in order to stop racism you have to
stop preaching it when it comes to faith
and religion if that's not done we're go
stay here yeah it's gonna be a little
bit of resistance to that yeah did you
enjoy it we in Detroit
there are 1968 when they went in they
painted Madonna black uh-huh so it was
called the shrine and a black madonna no
way Jesus was white I mean it's absurd
you can't tell me that cuz ice I saw him
my whole life he looked like he had yeah
pretty Brown here and everybody Robin
Thicke before he was the best-looking
German man a German guy without getting
is like we're just not gonna and you
know black people will defend that like
there's some black churches what nice
this hey let's take the picture the
white Jesus down they said no they said
no it doesn't mean anything I said it
means everything it means everything
because it means that if the Son of God
is white God is white if the son of John
Salley came out white we would blood
test right so if the Son of God is white
God is white that is establishing that
that's the supreme right so where do you
get white supremacy that's the beginning
of white supremacy super-interesting
yeah so did you see Cornel West talking
to Anderson Cooper on CNN the other day
I love ya I mean what a what an
incredible monologue or he is I mean I
was like so powerful and one of the
things he said was the
you know the blowback is coming like
make no mistake like they're there this
is not going to go quietly into the
night and just you know a home ana fest
you know beautiful change without a lot
of resistance to this so you know how do
you think about that like where do you
see that coming from and how do we you
know prepare for that I think I think
it's spot on
like there's is so interesting that
people want they want people to be
peaceful and protest they don't mind the
cops being aggressive and getting the
protesters out of there but when
somebody's mark like Dave Chappelle if
he just put out a forty saying that was
I know not to get too far so he but I
don't think anybody can bring a story
together like he can't like with so many
different aspects that just tie in
together but it's just like people have
to be willing to understand how long we
have been quiet it was like you see all
the memes like well we try to protest
peacefully by taking a knee nothing
happens trying to protest pieces on the
street nothing happens I try to protest
peacefully online nothing happens we
burn some [ __ ] everybody shows up hmm
well damn alright we're not you showing
up alright okay we're not you here now
let's talk you know and I'm with I'm
with John on this too late I don't know
man I know people work hard for their
businesses so I definitely don't want to
see that happen but I also know that
sometimes in order to get the point
across shit's gotta go down she's got to
go down I hate I hate I hate that and I
wish we could find if we can find
another way to get them attention but
then we also got a look at the setup
that comes along with this too late
nobody ever talks about this they talk
about the random bricks that just show
up all the time right people so but is
anybody ever tripped off why is there
always a random [ __ ] cop car for like
the extra scene you know Street Fighter
maybe just beat up the cop car and you
get all these extra points like it's
just always an empty cop car for
everybody to burn up and spray-paint it
beat the hell out of win on a lane like
a prop for a photo op across
that we can say that this is out of
control exactly went on a normal day
have you ever just seen a random cop car
on the street
with the windows now put the windows
down no cop around no God hey I tell you
this no one likes the truth yes why it's
a hard thing when you got to go in
yourself and check yourself and you know
how many times I had to check myself if
I wasn't being a house Negro or field
negro I had to check myself I wasn't
being housed and they used the word
Negro because it it's a little different
but do you think that's why the NFL
players acted the way they did with the
Kaepernick thing they were and you have
owners telling you if you do with you
out mmm we're finding you just what do
you think about what Goodell has said
well I I'm I got a text from Drew Brees
I text you Brees as soon as it happened
did you try said let me help you through
this let me explain it to you and then
he sent back a wonderful text saying
sorry I didn't get back to you obviously
I've been inundated but you know I
apologize I had to reach at what I was
saying what I meant and I said at the
wrong time but I now know where I was
wrong I was like perfect I love what
good I love you though I love wicked l
said and I think he should say we should
do this now and we should pay more
attention I think he's stepping up and
saying that great I'm glad he did talk
about giving people their jobs back on
all that all he can do is apologize for
mistakes but right now Kyrie Irving is
telling guys when they're trying to get
the NBA season to start back in Orlando
he's saying I don't think we should be
playing basketball right now and then if
the ball play if the black ballplayers
don't back Kyrie Irving I'm telling it's
gonna be easy getting at market pushed
out marginalized no the ones who don't
follow Kyrie Irving are the ones who
gonna get pushed out they don't get
pushed out from our community cuz I'm
gonna make sure of it those who don't
join the fight if you ain't with us you
against us George W Bush well the true
brinstead back to the drew brees thing I
mean that that whole situation kind of
perfectly in capsule
it's so much right here's a guy who just
said absolutely the worst possible thing
he could ever say in that moment and it
was just looking at that thing I was
just thinking how could he like what was
going through his mind that he thought
that was the right thing to do
grew up in a white neighborhood I will
give him my point yeah and then he got I
mean the whole world put him on blast
the internet just went insane I will
give him credit that he did a pretty
good job with his apology like he really
he didn't just walk it back and do kind
of like that you know the textbook like
he you could tell he put a lot of
thought into it and I do think it's
important in this moment where there's a
breakdown in civil discourse and we're
finding it more and more difficult to
actually just have hard conversations
where you John Salley can say you could
speak your mind you could speak your
truth that's why lucky we need to have
we need to have this like a headless of
your opinion or whether we disagree or
not like that is the path forward here
and right now our culture is so fraught
and everybody's so terrified of saying
the wrong thing
that a lot of people are sitting on the
sidelines and and remaining quiet in a
moment where I think we need to be
conversing in public out loud and when
you see Drew Brees and what he did we
need to understand that when someone
makes a mistake like that that we have
to provide them the opportunity to
redeem themselves we can't just cancel
them forever like if we want to grow and
learn from this moment right now we have
to be able to celebrate the winds and
figure out how to fan the flames of
positive change without just the you
know shoving a side of the people who
don't follow the line with whatever
talking points are deemed socially
acceptable in the moment yeah I think
that speaks to all aspects of this
problem from all different I think I
think and I believe in Kassel culture is
used too much but I do believe sometimes
it is needed like like I would say this
if breezes speech was one speech but his
interview if what he would have said was
straight hateful and you knew it was a
hateful
then that was different you don't say
anything just dinner just apologizing
that [ __ ] just doesn't work you know I
think we got to stop doing that to as
black people like well he apologized
even though he said I hate [ __ ] black
people and he applies that it's
different
we got situation like that where people
literally been hateful and but then they
start looking at their money their
dollar and they're like oh I need to go
apologize
don't apologize cuz it's the right thing
to do because you're probably wouldn't
say the first thing in first yeah let me
give you a little history George Wallace
was the governor of Alabama
when that walk across
Selma bridge happened and he wanted he
wanted exactly what happened when they
crossed the bridge people getting beat
everything to when the President had to
send the National Guard in to tell him
not to kill these black folks he then
had a stroke when he got older and his
nurse was black and literally saving his
life every day and he apologized and all
these black people put their hands on I
I got it in the jet magazine and my
mom's made sure I said you see some
people you can you can you can go back
and realize it'll come back to one day
the pupu that you heard he's gonna come
back and the ones you gonna you gonna
need and I thought about it I like all
of these guys I love what drew said yeah
I like today came back and I like that
when people like you said get a chance
to redeem themselves but he would not
have said that if he didn't grow up
thinking the other way that's why you
having us on this show me in particular
only be in my second time but don't
worry about it we were joking before the
podcast so the first time you came in
you just you got up in the middle and
said you know pick up your daughter
yeah you remember that oh yeah man so
she was uh right down the street from
your crib - yeah I was having to roughly
all the time that oh you in trouble I
know my daughter flipped out from 14 to
16 like tripped I was like yeah man I
was like hormones and penises will do
something crazy thing my eyes only for
just enjoying the ride don't wait to she
start smelling guys I'm a distance he
smells cute Jesus Christ what was going
on I wanted to write a book just on
raising daughters but I got killed man
have been tough all right but I stepped
on your point yeah man it's just you we
do we can't do to cancel culture and
people do make mistakes and black people
always always forgive just remember that
don't don't ever think that they hate me
they're never gonna get white people and
the reason I tell you to George Wallace
thing is because he was the most hateful
guy he was so mad to the University of
Alabama put them it was so funny in
Forrest Gump when they talk about
putting the football players and Bear
Bryant was like I don't care what you're
saying you know I'm putting them on the
field he was so hateful but when it came
down to when his life depended on it it
was only black people around him there
was no white folks around and he
apologized and he apologized apologizing
and I want y'all to realize that when
you make those apologies and their
heartfelt black people will put their
arm around you and it can't be a
one-time apology you might have to
apologize to rush your [ __ ] life but
be okay well that's in his momma house
the mama house remember that time but
I'm saying though cuz because the thing
is you might have put out a press
release you might have put out something
saying you apologize now but that don't
mean everybody else heard it right then
so you know I'm saying like but will
will circulate is all the negativity so
if it comes out like Drew Brees talking
about you know disrespecting the flag
all right you put out their press
release you know basically saying I'm
sorry I shouldn't
down there but that doesn't mean just
cuz you got over it that the other
person got over that you were talking
about mm-hmm so you might this is like I
mean if you insist are [ __ ] it's a
starting point you mess up you might
have to apologize for the rest of their
relationship and if you plan on having a
relationship with black people you might
have to apologize over and over and over
or make the living amends it's about I
mean it's not in the pudding for
everybody out there it's not proof is in
the pudding it's proof is in the put in
but people America like some crazy
badass but the proof is in the pudding
is actually what you put hey I gotta go
get my daughter you're talking too much
that's like my mentor my older brother
anyway so like I've been around him his
almost most of your life that you guys
knew each other I didn't know how will
you wanna when I first was a camp
counselor say the boys home we've noted
about 10 years
hmm about 10 years I would say it's
Friday no I wore his jersey no but when
I was a kid though oh really I was a fan
yeah I mean I didn't know he was [ __ ]
crazy
I saw I saw something I was you know I
just had my own sneaker right and I was
like one of the first guy happened like
of course she did I did my brother my
brother was honest and so it was called
a saga and we sold it at any shoe stores
cuz we thought yeah we only sell them
for $40 so people can afford that right
yeah same Marbury mentality they don't
cost that much to make and uh and I
somebody says you know mayhap al sagas
and
I swear I don't know if it's because I
started smoking weed 20 years ago I was
like I couldn't imagine jumping and
hitting somebody and my knees right now
just tweet it even thinking of really
all that self care rich rich guy like VD
I was playing this cool kid and this kid
didn't move and he went around me he
went around me so fast and my legs
didn't move which used to be just you
know it's like instant he went around me
so fast this way I looked at my legs I
said that's that's that's what weirdos
it is it my wife is that what happened
my legs don't work anymore I was like
huh how long ago it was ten years I'm 56
946 I knew that's why I couldn't
understand Kareem played he was 42
Robert Paris
Kobe playing to it I could not imagine
playing 20 years in there
it to me right now when I see people
that you still Rudd yeah I wish I could
I got some back stuff that I'm working
on yeah I guess what kind of products
you got for me oh man I got some
unbelievable I wouldn't mention I
wouldn't mention one company but they
didn't do the deal yet quanta a little
question yeah but definitely I wish my
legs still work the same there's another
coming to the same thing go through but
the [ __ ] work so like I they actually
got me thinking about playing ball again
like my kneecap error I had surgery on
both knees now they cool people oh yeah
I said no and I was like hey I can let's
go for a run my wife was like well I
don't want to hear you for five days she
goes the peloton's over there I was like
yeah I said no and they make walk they
came in the house and said guess what
this works for your height in this we
have another 7-footer throw no excuses
and here's some 15 I was like hmm I
gotta do this yeah but it's it's I tried
swimming again yeah it was great
that was great but yeah my mother made
me learn how to swim and I see you know
there's a really good swimmer secure she
kills his he yeah like that was no way
yeah man and then I get out of the thing
and act like wow like a where he's like
a great swimmer and I was like I got
this pool I'm gonna go swimming again oh
that [ __ ] is hard
oh now open organics is the name is but
they they got a CBD cream they're like
like put this way I was there like a 8
or 10 with my knees pain and I'm easily
at a 0 to 2 now Wow anybody that's been
through 8 to 10 pain will take 0 to 2
yeah you know heart beat now my she's
got me one to go play ball again but
probably the first time I step on the
court my bees are gonna be like no this
is not I can't even shoot a hook shot I
tried it I went on my court the other
day can I say I'm just you know what I'm
just gonna do some sure I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna judge you a quarter your
house yeah I'm not gonna jump that much
I'm just gonna do this man I took about
six shots I was like hit the bowl with
my puppy all right let's shift gears
here I want to talk about the doc can we
talk about the doc for justice yeah yo
name yeah you're gonna know we're
building up to it I want to hear what it
is but you partnered up with with our
boy Keegan who's the guy behind what the
health and cowspiracy tell us a little
bit about this movie I mean you guys are
still in production yeah well we were
scheduled to be done shooting in June
but with the pandemic and
we had to put it back so we're focused
on releasing it by the end of the year
the film is about social justice and
food justice do the millions of hip-hop
our current you know I mean by seeing
what the health this is like the
official follow-up to what the health um
and we've John's in the movie neo
my Styles P stick from there Prince Rory
Wacka Wacka we talked but he didn't he
didn't wanna do it we didn't talk about
it but uh you know and that's cool like
I know it's not for everybody like some
cuz we go very in-depth in this and
we're calling out major brands major
government all kinds of stuff
Wow and sometimes just everybody don't
wanna talk about it so I get I don't
hold it personal when nobody doesn't
wanna be in that committee or anything
like that but it's like the idea is it's
addressing food and justice and like
nutritional poverty and in ensuring also
like how certain foods literally are
detrimental to the health of people of
color I mean just like science has shown
it all these lab tests everything and
then the government still allows it to
be sold and one of the one of the
greatest stories I saw was a we were
looking at the advertisement from either
one of the major baby formula companies
and in and they showed them handing it
to me in the movie and he's handed to me
and I'm reading it and it literally says
mother's breast milk is not sufficient
for the growth of babies so you're
telling people which is targeted to
people of color that they're the thing
that makes creating humans since the
humans were a thing that's not good
enough that's why you need this baby for
that's full of [ __ ] cow's milk that's
detrimental to people color already so
70% of all allergies are related to the
ingestion of animal milk lactose lactose
intolerance so if you start them off
with that you're not even giving them
breast
like people don't even know how much DNA
is transferred to a baby from their
mother's breast milk not even from your
mother's breast milk yeah yeah yeah just
another human yeah yeah and and when you
and when you dial it back to the actual
mother the mother actually the breast
milk actually will change its formula
formula to fit what the baby needs
that's how crazy Sciences they're like
no no don't do that we got to figure it
out we got this product here for you we
need a lesson
we need the lesson the male African is a
reproduction mmm that's you could say it
what you want to say no we are in the
show the deal is they put Foods in the
reason I got involved is the first the
first title was they killing us
literally spelled in Ebonics
yeah they killing us not they are not
they're not maybe they are what I saying
that they killing us here's what I was
like keep that title of course
it literally means something more than
just it's a banach it's whale I just
said it is black American period yeah
but they change it hungry for justice
hungry for justice but now the official
title of the film is they're trying to
kill us
that's the official type not they're not
they are not is it they're they're
trying to kill us they are trying to
kill us which and that's what they're
showing that's what we're showing like
this whole system is set up to where
you're eating this certain food and it's
gonna lead to these multiple different
either ailments diseases whatever and
then when that happens now you have to
go get this peel the peel didn't work
long enough because none of the people
say that they cure anything they say
help you deal with this with the symptom
with the symptoms of so let's duct tape
like if you notice there's nothing out
there any of these commercials they'll
give you 85 side effects may cause anal
leakage and
oh [ __ ] but your headaches gone uh-huh
you don't say so you start to talk about
all these different things and if that
doesn't work
guess what 92 surgery now the surgery is
$30,000 and after surgery guess what you
got to do you got to take some more
pills to deal with the lack of whatever
we cut out of you right because you
can't produce it any more yourself or or
they don't talk about it's right over
here we got this food that you could
just eat that's like grown from the
ground and we'll talk a little bit about
how this impacts black and
african-american communities
disproportionately from other
communities could you make that argument
that that would be the case whoever the
customer is yeah you can say that that
is the case but what we've noticed is
fortunately that grocery stores are not
spread around the country evenly mm-hmm
so you look at lower-income communities
they'll have a bodega maybe they'll
maybe have a gas station and what we've
noticed is that people call it food
deserts it's not really food deserts is
nutrition deserts it's food there but
where's the nutrition in it you know you
got a pack of peanuts it's got eighteen
ingredients in it when all it needs is
just peanuts you know is it what you get
to see is that these people in these
certain demographics are predominantly
people of color so yeah you might have
and you give people with the you know
the outs outlying factor like yeah there
are some white people that live in this
community mm-hmm but predominantly is
people of color so that's what they're
showing and that's what we're showing is
that you're starting off already in a
negative plan right you know they're
already you let's say you come to top of
the mountain we gave them a five hour
head start and we gave them shoes you
know I'm saying now you get a big
mountain - you catch them you don't
saying like there's so many things
across the board without give it a whole
movie with you know like for instance
we're in LA right now if people want to
really see the difference
I want them to go to Beverly Hills and
tell me the address of the McDonald's in
Beverly Hills and if somebody actually
gives you the address of McDonald's in
Beverly Hills they're [ __ ] lying
because there's not one
there's not one McDonald's in Beverly
Hills you all fighting even though I use
I don't even know that uniform
Beverly Hills is 4.4 miles wide
supposedly you won't find a McDonald's
I'll find a Popeyes you'll find in one
car and one one one gasoline store and
it's the highest gasoline in the world
in the country
uh-huh oh that fancy one with the fancy
roof yeah and yeah I know I should
people still happen huh
so that's where you get to see where
they know what they're doing they're
putting things in certain areas to feed
the white America and the people coming
and just because you let me try to say
like that doesn't mean you're racist
that you've been a part of this this
matrix for so long it's like no but once
you realize it that's what leads to this
systemic aspect exactly sort of
reinforces this this you know the
disproportionate outcomes I mean when
you look at black Americans and the
incidence of diabetes and obesity and I
mean you compare you line that up
against white populations and it's
pretty shocking and it's what we've been
taught we've been conditioned to believe
that we have to eat any certain foods
we've been conditioned to believe that
we will have these certain ailments and
these certain diseases but nobody's
coming to tell us you know that's
actually preventable over there you
don't have to get this [ __ ] you know I'm
saying but we think we gotta have a
certain way to eat the guy and most of
that stuff if you trace it back start
off with slavery as well so you were
given this food and one thing about
black people we will turn anything you
give us into gold if you give us a
[ __ ] up situation we're gonna make the
best of it the problem is is that we're
still holding on that [ __ ] up
situation every time we eat these
certain foods and it's still keeping us
in this system the one thing is there's
a loophole there's a loophole like the
good food that's available out there is
available for everybody but they make
you see a dollar hamburger
and you think that that's a better value
but in reality you can get more fruits
and vegetables for the week under a
certain budget than you would if you
were to go buy steak and all these
process stuff but really part of the
deal is it's fast food and in our
community usually parents work more than
one job yeah and there's been a lot of
times where it's been single-parent home
by the single mom a single dad mostly
mom so mom doesn't have the time or the
wherewithal to go get those vegetables
make it into a meal unless the Ethiopian
the Ethiopian they know what to do with
the lentils in the corner you know
you're trained that way but in America
we're trained here take some money go
get you you and your sisters something
to eat and come back well go find out
let's go and whatever you can get for
five dollars is gonna be your food for
the night and the food that you're
getting is not food so it doesn't digest
but it swells your stomach and so if you
get no nutrients and you're getting no
strength then you have no ability to
fight if you got no ability to fight you
would have no ability to reproduce you
have no ability to reproduce they lessen
your sperm count they add tons of
obesity has gone through your
self-esteem has dropped and there's
crying on the street so you can't leave
your house so this is constantly put
into a situation to make us fight
amongst ourselves while being sick mmm
and that's that's where it comes into is
why like you said I did it and why we
had to put better restaurants but I'm
gonna get an argument from somebody no
matter what right when they were like
Sal I mean I was talking to Shaq and he
was like so I shouldn't eat fried
chicken right and I was like now you
know the and you eatin the skin too and
and there's oil and it's gonna get a
juicer okay I saw you telling you tell
about people not to eat chicken yeah
yeah but but his film is gonna hit like
he said you didn't get sued a lot always
sued but I think you're gonna void know
that you're smart how to stir it up yeah
sure right he's moving out a couple we
got a collective effort here like we I
mean it's funny I talk to him every day
like every day and we always come up
with like brainstorming ideas like oh
[ __ ] let's do this let's do this Oh cuz
you know when they see this they gonna
be pissed
perfect because we won't people cuz he's
a park goal his punk rock thing and this
is the thing to it for everybody out
there I don't want people to think that
Keegan is running this field I don't
know why people think like I had
somebody if I were you I would let them
think that because when they get sued
they disagree one of my posts like I was
like you know like all these vegan
corporations that and organizations that
are that reached out to me about like
hey we need to promote the black people
but now you're silent I'm like [ __ ]
y'all like like I'm being honest like no
[ __ ] y'all and they're like oh I hope
Keegan sees this and he drops him from
the film I'm like no I was like first of
all Keegan repost it like that plays
into the whole mindset of light well
I'll go report to the white guy that the
black guys are you know saying like the
mentality that comes with that is crazy
that's wild
yeah man but it's so our troublemaker I
am totally I am but but I'm only a
troublemaker because people don't want
to hold on to the old fake [ __ ] hmm
you're a troublemaker yeah like you know
like I mean vegan instagrams a [ __ ] show
the truth hurts so much if you live it a
lot that's if you live in a lie the
truth is gonna [ __ ] hurt you know
what I heard yesterday well oh my god it
was the greatest greatest thing
I got heckling and saying something and
he said don't worry about it because no
he goes you know what if you throw a
brick at a bunch of a pack of dogs only
the one that gets hit by the brick house
so the only the people that get up
exactly right are the ones who are going
to say something about what you're doing
exactly the ones that the brick hits the
wonder you hits them then they have
something they got something too how far
I guess I say that sounds like look I
don't I might put the shoe out there but
I won't name the name of the shoe I
don't even say what size of these but
it's always so [ __ ] come along
saying this shoe fits the shoe fits the
word like that's how I would be but I
don't name out anybody I'll name out the
actions and I'm like if you fit these
actions that's you
so we have no sponsors for we do have we
do have a crowdfunding going on for the
film and it's to to make sure that
people are involved in the film even
more than what they are the name of it
mmm
what is it crowdfunding it's gonna be on
our website they're trying to kill us
calm
they're trying to kill is that website
up right now yeah so is it's a only be
about time you put the shona how you
spell it how we spell it
they are there th ey re there's no
apostrophe on websites and by the time
this movie comes out I think John's
gonna win this argument has anybody made
a nutrition focused documentary about
the black and African acknow communities
people of color community well there was
one called invisible I don't want to
leave her out it was her otherwise just
like get healthy yeah yeah no I think I
think before her I don't think anybody
else really may want to focus on people
of color and it's so neat is is just I
don't think anybody was in a position to
make it mmm at the same time
like I just I've been fortunate to be
able to in a position where you know
Keegan's we've been friends for a long
time and he asked me he was like man I
want to do a film and I which you cuz
he's seen my work and other stuff I've
done social justice and always speaking
up and doing speeches and he's like
that's work together he's like I wanna I
want to reach a different demographic I
was like well you know like let's let's
go for the people of color like they
need us he's like yeah but I don't know
how I was like hip-hop like my first and
I did was like hip-hop I was like
hip-hop runs everything like and I say
powerful cultural force in the universe
if you ever if you ever want to
understand how strong hip-hop is say if
you close your eyes you can see a bunch
of six-foot white guys on skates with
jay-z playing in the background and you
just talked about the NHL yeah you know
saying like that's how powerful is the
biggest green yeah hip-hop is great but
you know look at the biggest Broadway
show right now I'm not saying hip-hop
infused you don't say it so it's like
what about unhealthy vegan so a we we
only talking about the black unhealthy
vegans or like when you say nutrition
like what what are we what are we what
point are we getting well we are trying
to get people to be healthy
that's the thing like there's there's a
big confusion of like veganism and
healthy veganism like they there are
some vegan products out there that taste
like burger tastes like cheese tastes
like that and sure in moderation but
what we're trying to do is get people to
be vegan for health it was about it was
about human in your movie you know what
is the path forward like what are the
solutions that you're for you know
providing people with that's that's one
of the biggest things is I want to be
solution based with the movie as one big
single total keygen so one of them is
we're working on actual programs like
more learning programs afterwards we're
showing them how to eat within the movie
showing them where to get fruits and
vegetables where to get nuts the legumes
and rice whatever it kind of be but how
to put it together that's beneficial to
them as well like we also I don't want
them to feel like are
we gave you this problem but we didn't
show you how to yeah I'm showing them
like a lot of the different studies and
everything showing how the reversal of
all these diseases can be incorporated
with this plant-based eating vegan
eating whatever case is one of the
biggest things to is that we were
working on a actual meal plan like
actual product to be very affordable so
you know we do see that like a lot of
the vegan items are out of the price
range for a lot of people actually had
some talks with a store brand Whole
Foods if you're listening let's get that
going but we were working on having it
to where people who watch the film they
could get these meal plans from Whole
Foods at an affordable rate my aunt also
have them delivered since before the
pandemic you know delivery was still
today with Whole Foods and having it
delivered to them because when I had a
meeting with Whole Foods I told my was
like you know you can build a Whole
Foods in the hood right next door to her
mom with six kids and she's still not
coming cuz for her to get all six kids
in the car get them ready or even if
it's a dad I don't want to sound wrong
way whoever parent a single parent with
kids for them to get them in the car get
them over there give him that but now if
we provide a solution we're literally
putting it on the doorstep for this is
hard to me all you gotta do is heat it
up you don't saying and I'm not this is
not like a just making it easy as
possible right and like expanding the
perimeter the delivery perimeter also
because those Whole Foods are far away
and we're talking about Amazon you know
you know they have the capability to
reach everybody
they're already delivery like one I have
the to where they give it to them there
I know I mean while is I have been in
talks with other stores as well so if it
does work out with Whole Foods
it's gonna work out right whatever the
solution is it's got to be convenient
convene for double you know easy and
there has to be an education days to hey
if you don't want us to make stuff
here's also stuff that you can do at
home on your own get the kids involved
so I think that's a big thing to is like
involve our kids in the process of
making our food uh-huh
so when the food is on the table like
why did you give me this you know and so
now it's like involving the whole family
if they have time because we also know
like you said you got single parents or
whatever working two three jobs I was
raising a single family household you
know my mom was working her ass off
because she was a manager for Bell South
or Pacific Bell but it was something
where we were and as a black person in
the 80s as a management role a black
lady at that she was putting in extra
hours that the white guy that worked
under her wasn't even for men because
she had to show that she was capable of
the stripe so you know I ate chicken
damn near every night cuz it was frozen
chicken from Sam's Club yeah it was easy
I unplugged my microwave yeah told my
daughters of a bro but and then one day
I just thought of putting Corey Webb
told me I just put a whole bunch of
dishes in there so when they went to use
it I made that was all it took just puts
dishes in there again yeah they had to
learn how to cook and I was glad you
said I've got teaching it's it's a trip
it's a thing that hasn't been around my
mother made me learn how to do
everything
but yeah it's uh I can't wait for your
movie to come out it's exciting matter
thank you it's exciting I now like
covetous like push it back a little bit
yeah you got some I want to retake just
I got more muscles now that I've been
able to work out I'm framing my body
back I think I was really soft enough I
think my body was soft my body stronger
the power that a document like that
holds to really shift culture is is
super exciting
yeah yeah and that and it's where look
you know the whole vegan thing the vegan
movement it's so super whitewashed you
know it's just like you know aspiration
of like the well-heeled and you know
that needs to get that narrative needs
to get shifted and you know the fact
that you're doing that is but you know
what I found out when
and I'm gonna say it this way when white
folks are vegan and into natural way of
eating they are more empathetic and they
understand slavery what I mean by that
they don't know it directly but they
don't want the animals enslaved and they
will understand the horrific treatment
of animals and that black folks at one
time was submitted to the same level and
still considered it's a better feeling
when I'm around vegans then I'm around a
flesh-eater
well I'm around a flesh-eater you know
they still think well I can take my gun
and go shooting a deer and then I'm cool
and I go why don't you go hunting with
it everybody got a gun hunting a sport
is like now a sport is when all parties
involved northern a part of the game
yeah like when you think about it the
the overlap between you know how I would
like to think about myself approaching
this situation am i you know how I think
about vegan is I mean there's a huge
overlap right this is about like
compassion it's about you know being
open to new ideas it's about you know
challenging your assumptions and you
know sort of undoing some of that
programming like none of us were born
vegan we lived a certain way in a
certain way we made a change and you
know I would like to believe that it's
made me a more compassionate person but
it has been interesting to kind of watch
how the vegan community is grappling
with what's happening right now
and you know some are doing it well and
some are not and that's disheartening to
me because this is about compassion and
I would hope that everybody can you know
think about that a little bit in terms
of like how they're communicating and
navigating what's happening yeah I think
I think also is just that one thing that
I saw that was kind of like kind of
weird is that how you'll see vegans
compare modern-day
agriculture animal agriculture - slavery
is a well if you speak that way then why
wouldn't you speak up for the
descendants of that same slavery like
they that's the funny thing like they
feel like they can't speak up about it
oh no we only speak up for the animals
like yeah but if you are gonna use
slavery as your you're speaking note
then you got you can't be hypocritical
by now you have to remember you know I'm
sayin like and I see that so many times
across the board there use that so fast
it's like modern-day slavery
okay well then if it's my day slavery
you understand how powerful slavery was
and how it trickled down and how the
effects can still be here but you don't
say anything
we are rich roll now they gotta say he's
gonna edit this [ __ ] good about 15
minutes I'm sponsors in the Friday is he
gonna let up some somebody he'll figure
out how to put original [ __ ] I'd do
her I know I knew it now that was my
thing I'm gonna just keep going kids
away and my wife and I whoa hey my name
is thank you I gave it to you oh wait
about this this is good so anybody can
do the research so I was a father today
that they when you talk about the the
trickle-down effect of racism and how
it's just been in place for so long so
you know the ice cream man you know the
truck when it comes around and has that
song playing in the background so there
was a song that that actually came from
and in the lyrics he was like
[ __ ] love watermelon in the song so
it is is a poster right now and they
actually it was recorded for Columbia
Records in like 1926 or 36 really maybe
21 yeah so they you can find this song
and the view the video that went along
with it is like this gray and white
cartoon depiction of blackface and these
may be showing them being excited about
eating watermelon and excited about
being huh it's just serves like those
little things they turn that of course
they made it like instrumental out of it
but that shows you how long [ __ ] has
just been thrown into black people's
face and they're like no get over it
it's like now you don't get over it like
jingle bells - yeah jingle bells yeah
jingle bells the national anthem like
yeah you know late yeah and we only had
to go in detail just people start
googling their actual lyrics to these
songs and then you see why people get
frustrated sigh dude it's right in our
face but everybody's like just get over
it it's okay it's okay like thing no
it's not okay yeah this is gonna be a
great year 2020 how about 1920 that was
the thing it was you know the rate in
20s it was like roaring roaring Tron
he's like so weird I like the co vid 20
yeah but we got to come up with this 20s
is something it's something I don't know
what it is whatever they say it is the
Eurovision I think it's just showing us
some things we weren't really looking
for but it's showing it's a lot of [ __ ]
yeah like 20 shows we surely we can do a
lot yeah no I'm saying it's like we can
do a lot and I say that my mother passed
this year and then the day after I
buried her Kobe died and then that was
tremendum II happened crashed and then
President Trump took over the Fed and
then
what happened double lockdown Hilary's
in court for you no no it was crazy
about there too late Irish uh he'll tell
you I randomly just hit him up all the
time like a just wanna see who's I just
see those up and I don't know it's
something gave me a feeling and that's
when I I text him he was cleaning out
his mom's apartment at the time and some
just told me to text when I got out
house I'm leavin [ __ ] respond
that's not sure but that's our
relationship like he'll hit me like hey
man you need to watch this take care it
is like a big brother mentor kind of
like being that we got so and then when
he hit me back about his mom and like
damn like I just but some told me to hit
him up and then right after that it's
funny cuz I was in LA I was like hey I'm
in LA I mean you know because I know if
I come to LA and I'll tell him even if
I'll see him it's a problem if I come to
LA and he found out later then I'm gonna
know anyway yeah so I was like hey I'm
just so lucky I don't chase broads
entire I told him like yo like I'm in LA
he said I'm doing this and then the next
day was Kobe and I was like [ __ ] so I
had to hit next day so I had to hit him
back after that I was like damn I just
heard about Kobe man like I know he was
close with Kobe so I hope you good man
if you mean I'm gonna need me I'm here
but if you I want those people to like I
don't I hate hitting the people during
like bad times cuz I already know 8,000
people hitting them up you know it's
better it's always good people need to
notice hit people up during the tough
times not a good time right right know
when it when [ __ ] is flying don't hit
them and see you I see you morally go in
them with that you know clap from a
distance but when there's tough times
let people know yeah and say if you need
to call me back I'm here if not dude I
totally understand I'm not one of people
like well I called him and they didn't
called me back as I got us ego like let
that person deal with the situation how
they gonna do just let them know you're
there
yeah just oh I'm here if you need me you
probably don't need me but if so I'm
here yeah we should read it the view I'm
getting
good luck lesson to put a pin in it you
gotta get John out of here man he's
getting antsy yeah all right Stevie
thanks guys
yeah Thank You Lance everybody
[Music]